how do you respond to republicans who
try to paint you and your party
as anti-police they're lying
what about defunding the police though
because there's no i've never never
never said to funding the police
so let's refresh his memory on which
party wants to cut funding to the cops
yes i support the defund movement not
only do we need to defund
but we need to dismantle and start a new
why use the word defund why use the word
defund and it's like this is the word
that's coming from the streets
i am for defunding the police a moment
to reimagine lisa
in many cities in america over one third
of their city budget goes to police
so we have to have this conversation do
we agree that we can redirect some of
the funding
yes absolutely
jessica the floor is yours
don't fall on it
so joe biden the question if it was just
have you
ever advocated to defund the police joe
biden would be right to say
they're lying joe biden has never
advocated for that i said redirect
redirecting is not actually defunding
defunding means
they said redirect money from the police
right
to to what you're going to make out for
like nail salons
to have they've even done this in new
york city actually there's some
preliminary results that sending some
9-1-1 calls to people like social
workers
is making a big difference versus
sending police
i'm just telling you the facts about it
she's pointing the gun at me come quick
but that's not all the calls that go to
9-1-1 obviously
so they just said let's drill down on
this so you're saying the the 9-1-1
operator waits
and then listens and then slowly makes a
determination whether or not to send
real 9-1-1
or whether it deserves a social worker
you think that that's just
split second decision that's going to be
good every time it's not necessarily
going to be good every time but if you
can
have some more i was the victim i wanted
to be good every time
oh okay but not every call to 9-1-1 is
he has a gun
a lot of people call 9-1-1 for other
sorts of things where that a police
officer showing up
armed is not going to be the right
approach but either way obviously the
montage is real
every member of the squad advocated for
this nancy pelosi didn't whip clyburn
didn't
joe biden didn't people in positions of
power it is obviously a bad issue for
democrats we don't want to go into the
midterms with it hanging around that's
all we wanted you to say
well why didn't you just say that um i
could have avoided two minutes of chat
all right greg uh i mean it's pretty bad
that your
biggest defenses
they did it it's i do not blame joe
biden at all he clearly doesn't have the
internet
and he also doesn't watch fox because if
he stuck to his
normal uh uh menu of news
he may not never heard this before it
was like the fine people hoax it was
news to him that it wasn't true that's
why they stopped it took him like a year
to stop saying it
but uh and also he doesn't get any
pushback from the plant media you saw
don lemon just you know
nodding along like he's listening to
josh groban
uh joe's like an undisciplined kid he
can
break things and throw tantrums but the
doting parents
are the media and they do oh he's so
adorable when he lies isn't that cute he
or maybe he really believes that
no one will ever call him on it so the
bigger problem here is i think that the
dems have turned a basic need
into a political football and the people
playing with that football
are immune to the consequences of their
actions they're behind gated communities
we say that over and over again but
there's a weird
let them eat cake thing here especially
among the national news media
it's not happening happening exactly
outside their door so they don't really
care
i think the solution will not come from
republicans because no one's going to
listen to them
no one's going to listen to fox they're
going to listen to people like jessica
or harold ford
moderate democrats have to expunge
the elite activist class we're
deliberately subverting
our nation by unraveling the basic
tenets of justice
and the only people who can do that are
democrats like jessica you guys have to
make a stand
like if we have nutters you know on the
other side
we're pretty good about booting them to
the street it's time because you're you
got to you got a nut you've got a nugget
of nut bags you want to destroy this
country
boot your nutters jessica and then when
you're finished
don't these uh people empower these left
wing nuts
to use your word don't they listen to
the family members who are on local tv
and on fox news who have lost their
loved ones who
uh there was a woman on earlier on fox
news whose
son was murdered and the prosecutor
uh the circuit attorney cut a deal
on her son's murderer and she they i
guess they're ignoring that
um and they're also there's a bigger lie
that's going on here and by the way joe
biden
and i say this over and over and over
again joe biden and kamala harris
both propose getting rid of cash bail
that is the revolving door that has
caused a spike in crime
here in new york and in other places but
they're all part of this liberal
ecosystem
from the lunatics in washington the
left-wing the governors
the mayors the city councils the
district attorneys who have
implemented these policies that pamper
the perpetrators
and gavin newsom said something
yesterday and i want to push back on it
i forgot i forgot to yesterday
he said the evidence doesn't back it up
over the last three decades we've
actually seen a significant decline
in crime in his state and they say it
about other places
you know why because there are policies
in place that you have ripped up
he's talking about three decades where
it was
conservative policies that crack down on
crime they put people in jail
and i just wanted to point out just like
here in new york in california
the violent crime rate was up last year
the rape rate
um fell but aggravated
aggravated assault increased and so he's
again focusing on he's trying to take
credit for something that he didn't do
well he's being very dishonest because
they're not recording the crime
so if you don't arrest anybody or if you
don't prosecute anybody it's not in the
record and you can say hey look the
statistics are less than last year so
therefore crime is going down
but you don't have to be part of the
literal defunding
monetarily of the of the police to
defund the police i mean
democrats across the board have adopted
the blm message
the black lives matter movement they
didn't speak out last summer when cities
were burning and they were causing two
billion dollars worth of damage which of
course demoralized the police
they act they basically painted every
single police officer in the country
with this racism
argument that if you're a white police
officer you're out to get black men
every single time you wake up and put on
your badge and go out in the street
that's demoralizing which is why you're
seeing these mass retirements and
nobody's signing up
to do the job and also you know it's
amazing that democrats have embraced blm
which has proven itself to be
not a movement interested in black lives
or else they would speak out again
on all this crime that's happening in
black neighborhoods but really about
enriching themselves and
and taking the country into more of a
marxist style of economy
rather than the capitalist society we
have now and so you don't have to say
i support defund or dismantle like aoc
or
ilhan omar to be part of that movement
democrats thoroughly embraced a movement
that emboldened criminals
and demoralized police officers across
the country all right hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else